30 minute workouts
20 minute recipes 10 minute mindfulness
ready to become
[Music]
get feel on the app store or google play
hey everyone it's joanna here welcome
back to another workout session today's
workout is a low impact core functional
training this workout will work on your
strength as well as mobility and we want
to be engaging our core throughout the
entire workout because it's low impact
there will not be any jumps and there
will be a lot of new as well as
interesting movements so get yourself
ready and let's have some fun
[Music]
let's start with a quick warm-up okay so
i want you to start by standing shoulder
width apart with your toes pointer
forward bring your legs up open up to
the side and back down okay so working
on your balance as well we want to
really work on the mobility of the hips
and to really open up your hip flexors
up
out and back down okay so find your
balance engage your core suck your belly
in tighten the abdominal muscles and
bring your leg as high up as you can
one step at a time
right leg up to the side point your
knees out toes pointed down and back
down good
few more
back down
one more on each side
and back down okay let's get into some
side lunges okay so what i want to do is
take your right leg out to the side step
back in and now to the side so you
should feel the stretch on your inner
thighs as well as your glutes step in
the middle and out
good try to push your butt back
and keep your body upright
out
and in good job
keep going this is your warm up
so i want you to really engage your body
fully focus on every movement
and really feel your muscles warmed up
out and in
last step hands down
one more to the left
and up okay now step wide with your toes
pointed out and bring your hands down
one way to do is get into a deep squat
straighten your legs feel the stretch in
the hamstring
down
straighten your legs
feel the stretch in the hamstrings back
down and up okay if you can
try to place your palms
on the floor if this is too much for you
then just raise up
and back down
and up okay find your comfort level up
and down for a deeper squat
down push your butt back
down and up really feel that deep
stretch
in your hamstrings
back down
up
one last one
and up all right now
let's step right at the edge of your mat
i want you to slowly just inch forward
into a plank
and slowly
inch back up stand up right
slowly inch forward
into a high plank
flat back
and slowly come back up one more time
inch forward
high plank
and slowly inch back up all right
for the first workout if you have a
towel grab a towel okay the first
workout is going to be a deep squat so
what i want to do is stand straighter
with the pot with your twist pointer
forward grab your towel with your arms
above your head
squat down push your butt back and up
okay so both arms
should be up at all times and i want you
to really create the tension
and pull the towel apart if you don't
have a towel don't worry about it
this is to make sure that you're keeping
your body and your chest upright good
squat down push your butt back and up
making sure that your knees do not go
over your toes so as you can see all the
movements are really slow but what i
want you to really focus on is your
posture and your thumb okay
up
and back down okay good
drop the towel
the second workout is going to be a
cutscene lunge to a side lunge so
start in the middle
curtsy
cross over and step to the side
to a side lunge okay step in the middle
curtsy
and to the side
good so we're working on your total body
but again all these movements will
involve your core
engaging your car
or getting getting a strong core it's
not about doing crunches but rather it's
about doing total body workouts curtsy
as low as you can side
really push your butt back engage your
glutes feel the stretch on your inner
thighs
back and curtsy
good
so remember
stand upright throughout the workout
do not
lean your body forward okay
last one more could see
step
out
and in all right good job now let's get
down onto the floor
bridge kick okay so support your body
bend your left knee keep your right leg
straight what i want you to do is
raise
your hips up kick
squeeze your glutes feel the squeeze on
your left glutes and try to drive your
right leg as high up as you can
and slowly return it
back down kick it up point your toes can
you feel your left glutes working
as well as your hamstrings okay kick it
up
nice
push
keep going feel the shake that's what we
want
point it down
up
keep going i can really feel
my left butt okay
nice point it down
kick
back down nice and controlled kick
back down and now slowly come back up
all right let's get to
the edge of your mat okay
backroll this is a really good call
workout as well as a total body movement
start in all fours
get on top get and what i want to do is
slowly crawl forward to the edge of the
mat and slowly inch back okay
so the key here is to make sure that
your back is flat and your butt is down
all right do not pike your butt up this
is wrong keep it low
flat back
strong arms strong shoulders tighten
your core
and slowly inch
forward
and back
alternate hands with alternate legs
keep going inch just like a bear
back
you should really feel your legs your
thighs your core as well as your
shoulders working
okay good
all right
final workout for this circuit and we
want to repeat the entire second once
more
downward dog to plank okay so start in a
high plank
push your butt back
feel the stretch
lower yourself down into a high plank
tighten your core do not dip
and push your butt back again
so this is also a nice active recovery
again
mind body connection
take this time to really
feel every inch
of your muscle working
engage the core
and really work
on your total body push it back
do the stretch on your back
into a high plank
a few more
and remember to just
breathe okay
good high plank
and slowly drop your knees very very
well done all right we want to repeat
the entire second once more so if you
have a towel grab your towel if you
don't have a towel that's absolutely
fine as well
first workout deep squat okay so
remember with a towel
pull it apart keep your arms up open
your chest stand up right
toes pointed
forward and really push your butt back
into a deep squat ready let's go push it
back
and up
slow
squeeze your glutes as you come up
down and up good job so do not drop your
arms
high up okay feel the tension
in your shoulders as well good push your
butt back
push up with the heels and squeeze your
glutes
keep going squeeze it
nice remember do not jerk okay
nice and controlled
you should also feel your back muscles
working by lifting both arms up down
up
squeeze
down
up give me one more
down
and up okay
drop the towel
all right
curtsy to a slight lunge so we have
worked on our right side let's work on
our left leg okay so stand in the middle
drive your right leg back
to the side feel the stretch
back again
and to the side
again find your balance
maintain an upright position
look straight ahead cross over
and slide so it's going to work on your
outer glutes
your thighs
as well as your inner thighs good cross
step to the side and push
really power
through your heels
good
keep going step
nice
nice and controlled movement
good
remember that you want to really bring
your right leg across
by maintaining an upright position
forward good all right now let's get
down
onto the mat bridge kick okay so we've
worked on our left glutes now let's work
on our right side so bend your right
knee
straighten your left leg now let's kick
it up
lower it back down kick it up
lower it back down good
up
remember to hold it for at least one
count at the top
squeeze your right glutes
up
lower it down
and up
good
hold up
point your toes let's go
up
and higher
remember to keep your hips squared okay
do not tilt your hips to the left or to
the right
up and down
push
through
your feet
up
[Music]
it's burning
and down okay
my favorite workout background all right
let's start at the edge of our mat
get onto all fours
hover your knees off
ready flat back let's go crawl forward
inch forward and back
good if you have a bigger space you can
go further forward okay
if not
just as far as your mat
keep going
knee touching your elbow
and back
do not pike your butt up
very good
and gaze
on the floor
good keep going
forward
tuck your belly in feel the burn
on your thighs
your
glutes and
back down all right
final workout
downward dog to plank okay
and we will get a short break all right
let's get into a high plank maintain
this high plank position and now push
your butt back
and back into a plank
i want you to try to get your heels
on the floor okay
push your butt back
push into the ground heels on the floor
and back into a high plank
look between
your thighs
and back
good push it
stretch it out and
back very good
and
back
good keep going feel the stretch
feel the work do not drop right now
stay in a high plank position
maintain this last one more
and back and slowly drop your knees
all right
that is the end of our first circuit
take a short one minute break and we
will move on to the second circuit with
a lot more interesting movements to
really work on your mobility
grab some water
[Music]
for the second circuit we'll be working
on our mat so the first workout is going
to be a crab toe touch so we want to
start in a reverse plank position sit on
your butt with your palms on the floor
fingers pointed forward and raise your
hips off the floor feet firmly planted
on the ground okay and what i'm going to
do is try to reach for the opposite side
so try to reach for your toes all right
and as you raise up try to lift your
hips off the floor feel the slight
crunch
on your abs good so do not
drop your butt down
maintaining a high
bridge position rich
and rich again if this is too much you
can always reach for your calves or your
ankle okay
up
and up good can you feel the engagement
on your core
lots of core work in order for you to
balance yourself
keep going
and up
good
point
reach
and reach
crunch
and good okay
back down all right the next workout
it's one of my favorite lateral lateral
plank walk with a push-up so start at
the edge of your mat
what i'm going to do is start in a high
plank position
walk to the side as you reach the end
give me one push up
walk again
and one push up okay you can choose to
do a full push-up or
a push-up on your knees down
up
and walk
again remember as you
walk to the side do not
dip your hips
nice
and thumb
foundation okay
down
push up good keep going
give me two more push up okay one
let's go back
maintain and back up all right very good
okay
let's get
down onto the mat
russian twist all right you can start
with both
heels on the floor and all i need to do
is lean back slightly
twist
to the side
okay so try
to get
your hands to the opposite side remember
you're twisting your torso it's not just
about moving your arms the entire torso
should be twisting to the left and to
the right
if this is too easy what you can do is
raise both legs up
a little bit more challenge and twist
okay
keep your knees together
and twist
good final balance nice and easy
do not rush through the workout and get
your core
feel that shake
that's one few more
left and right
and good
all right
a little bit more challenge okay
half turkish get up this is a love-hate
relationship all right
lie
flat on your back
bend your left knee
left hand up
place your right hand to the side and
what i'm going to do is straighten your
right leg and
using your core try to get yourself
off the floor and push your hips up
your left hand should be in a straight
line throughout so if you want to
challenge yourself what you can do is
grab onto a dumbbell okay push
up
this is a half turkish get up and
remember as you lower yourself down
slowly come back down to the floor do
not just collapse
keeping your left arm straight
and back down
up push it up
very good
all right
are we ready for another new movement
half scorpion twist okay so start in a
high plank position
what i'm going to do is
lift your right leg off drop it to the
side
and slowly release your right side and
slowly come back into a high plank same
thing left leg off and slowly release
your left arm and then using your core
come back in the center are we ready
find your balance and
arms
engage your core back
left leg slowly peel yourself off
and back into a high plank one step at a
time
arms and leg
left leg
left arm
good come back into a high plank
find that center
gravity
and back
find your balance all right very good
job okay
guess what we want to repeat the entire
circuit once more okay
and we'll work on the other side all
right so the first workout is going to
be a crap toe touch
start start on your butt
okay remember that your upper body is
just to support you
really engage your core
feet firmly planted on the ground let's
lift off
okay
really push your pumps into the ground
and now let's go reach
and reach
keep your knees slightly bent and try to
reach i don't want you to rush through
the workout i want you
to really engage your core
and take it step by step
every inch of your body should be
working in sync together let's go push
your hips up
reach
do not collapse slowly lower your legs
and your palms back to the floor
up push it up good reach let's go higher
good
up nice
lots of different workouts today
different movements
and this is a total body functional
training good all right let's get off
lateral plank walk with a push-up okay
so start at the edge of your mat
start in a high plank position
ready
hips squared let's go to your left
remember do not dip
push up one push up
back to your right good keep your hips
squared
back flat
one nice push-up
keep going
good
and just pace your breathing okay
let's see how many we can fit in
all right
down
let's go at least
two more
push up
back
wobble push up
and back
down
right
russian twist
this is a really good workout to work on
your obliques okay
so choose your option either heels on
the floor or heels off the floor okay
heels off find that balance and start
twisting
to the left and to the right
don't rush through
we're not
sprinting through this workout
we're doing it one step at a time
and really engage
your core muscles
twist and feel your obliques
all right
twist your torso not your arms your
entire body
left and right
good
suck your belly in
i can feel your burn
last 10 seconds
stay with me
few more
two
and one all right
okay
are we ready for our half turkish get up
all right let's lie down now straighten
your left leg
bend your right knee
right arms up
left hand out okay you'll find that one
side will be harder push yourself peel
yourself off lift it off
and back down so keep your elbows down
on the floor
right hand straight up do not bring it
forward
slowly lower yourself back down
push
feel the engagement on your hips
as well as your core
push
good
and back down
up
good there you go
very good
if this is too challenging for you
remember you can just
lift your upper body up
come back down okay if not let's go all
the way up
and down all right
my favorite
movement
half scorpion twist
you got this okay
let's get our body in sync and get your
coordination right high plank all right
let's go right leg off
right hand off
back right palm right leg
left leg
left arm good back into a high plank
and the opposite side
flat good there you go
really engage your core
find that balance
very good
and i want you to look up
nice there you go
release and look up
remember to keep your hips up throughout
okay do not
drop your hips
let's go two more
back
that's one more
back
and we are
done
all right
that is the end of a total body
functional training with a focus on your
core
let's end with a quick cooldown okay so
let's get
onto your knees
what i want to do is drive your right
leg forward
and i want you to just
place both palms down
raise your legs off
and just stretch okay feel the stretch
on your left
inner thighs as well as hip flexor
and just stretch if this is too much
drop your left knee onto the floor if
not come up
back flat and stretch
good and
if you can try to drive your right butt
lower
and just hold it there good and now what
i want to do is
release your right hand
place it behind your waist
and just twist slightly okay
this is going to still work on your
balance
as well as your flexibility and just
hold it right here
and now slowly lower it back down change
legs push it back
left leg
forward and just drop
your right
leg again if this is too much you can
drop your knee onto the floor if not
bring it up
and just find that
balance
good
deep stretch
and now release your right hand final
balance place it behind your waist and
just gently twist and look to the side
and breathe
all right good and now release
let's slowly
come back up
all right
let's stretch our quads as well as our
inner thighs okay so
stand wide with your toes pointed out
what i'm going to do is get into a deep
squat
palms together push your thighs out okay
using your elbows push your thighs out
and just hold this position
all right you should really feel the
stretch on the inner thighs
and really just hold it right here
good
and we want to bring our heart rate down
so just breathe
[Music]
okay push it out
this is a really good inner thigh
stretch
all right and now slowly
come back up
this is one of my favorite
stretches what i want to do is link both
arms together
lower yourself down drop and just relax
your upper body
with the straight legs just swing
from the left to the right
keep your legs straight and you can
really feel the shift
from the left to the right
and the stretch on your hamstrings
really just relax your upper body okay
no tension
good swing
and swing okay
now get back up
point your right toes out
and now let's just reach for your right
toes and let's just
stretch it up
good so left arm up
lengthen your body
if this is too much grab hold of
your calves okay
for a deeper stretch go
lower
and now come back up same thing point
your left toes out to the side
let's go reach down
and slowly straighten your right hand
and stretch
and slowly come back up well done guys i
hope you enjoyed this workout do this
workout regularly at least two to three
times weekly to increase strength and
mobility this is a really great total
body functional training with the focus
on your car if you enjoyed this video
then check out other workout videos on
my youtube channel give this video a
thumbs up share it on and if you haven't
yet subscribed to my youtube channel
then do hit the subscribe button alright
hop on to my channel and check out a lot
more workout videos healthy recipes as
well as nutritional tips and i will see
you next time all the best